what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pre-game
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos also
if you guys want to see exclusive behind
the scenes content sign up for our
memberships and while you're at it send
a super chat we will read it during our
breaks today i have a panel of lovely
guests and to start why don't we go
around everyone say your name your age
your relationship status and where you
are from come on day number three uh
name's eddie 28 single pringle so give
me a shot
[Laughter]
what's up everyone back on the show jt
king bevs 25
from hackney congo come on
hi i'm tegan i'm 19 and i'm from wales
and i'm single
i'm ellen i'm just turned 28 yesterday
i'm from california and also single
thank you
my name is trevor and i'm single and i'm
from sheffield
i am silly talks i am 35 i'm single
okay so
today
the topic is the streets
are calling again we're talking about
only fans models so
i
came across a story that says only fans
models sex workers feel a pinch of the
sluggish economy i'm working harder than
ever okay the plunging economy has been
hard on one particular sector sex
workers who say that the hot that the
decades high inflation has forced their
clients to cut back on discretionary
spending ali ray a 38-year-old
massachusetts woman who left her 84 000
a year nursing job to earn a monthly
six-figure income on only fans told the
post on friday that she and other online
creators have seen their incomes take a
hit recently many top recreators are
hurting bad race ad it's definitely
something that's happening
ray who during the pandemic earned as
much as 200
dollars a month told the post that her
income has fallen 25 in the recent weeks
other only fans performers have seen
incomes drop by as much as 50
my traffic has been down a lot i'm
working harder than i have ever been
so
my question
for today to start is only fans a real
job
there is because you've got an income
but it's not when you think about it
okay what do you guys think i think it
is a real job it is a real job any any
any job where
you have to
um
[Music]
you have to display a form of talent on
something then and you earn income from
um
can be considered work you know it's
just the platform that they're using it
on okay
i i think it's a job they are providing
the service at the end of the day and
they're getting paid for that service
therefore is a job how long term a job
is it's another question but yeah
it's basic form it's a job
i think the longevity is kind of
irrelevant if you have a regular income
from something that you're doing that
does classify as a job
because it's more of a physical job like
it's like saying you're a model like
the longevity is not long like
your age or catch up or whatever it's
kind of like only fans models like it
will it's not like a long-term job but
it is a stable income for the time being
as you're doing it
so oh yeah
it's definitely a job the sex work is
definitely a job they work very hard
they do
would you say do you think they work
hard they do i agree i do agree having
to like pretend someone is like if i you
know you have to pretend to be
pleasurable you know you could be going
for something in your life and i've got
go and perform on stage in my room to
camera and be like i'm loving this when
you're not so the answer is yeah it's
hard work you know it's hard work being
a plumber an engineer yeah an
electrician yeah
only fans yeah taking your clothes off
on camera yeah but they also it's not
like being a prostitute on the street
you also have to market what you do like
they are freelancers essentially so they
have to
what's it
but a lot of street marketers as well
they market themselves they're just on
their own but in the sense of you have
to
think about it from a business point of
view like how am i going to market
myself to
maximize my potential income whereas if
you're a prostitute on the street like
there's only so much you can do tell me
tell me an only fans marketing strategy
i'm not on only fans
like little bits coming soon you go to
all the porn site all the porn sites put
a little bit of 15 50 second teaser that
sounds like a lot of hard work it is so
hard i mean i
make programs for a living they aren't
hard work it's fun but it's hard work so
for me maybe i'm thinking about as a
talent point of view or some production
point of view
um some people are not good at sex
definitely a talent it's not a talent
not everyone's good enough
for your talent but wait obviously you
have to remember you're not just having
sex in it so we're talking about the
generalized idea of what goes on only
fans you're not just banging in it so
like there's the more artistic
expression of the nice
pictures in the lingerie and blah blah
blah
banging someone on camera doesn't
require talent yes you're good at it
banging someone on camera
so you have to be good at it not
everyone's good at sex or orgasm in
women and it's more of like the acting
thing like you need the person to
believe it like
it's not the same but a lot of only fans
created they're very similar to actors
like if they don't believe it they're
not all of it it's amateur porn because
if you look at brazil oh wait say it
say quorum
oh yeah you could say that about any
actor who's had their first lead role
though that's amateur action isn't it
because it's their first book so so i'm
just got a question we're gonna put mia
khalifa okay it's the same thing as like
johnny depp in terms of talent yeah
well no because obviously johnny depp is
doing like talented he's not he's doing
different talented he's talented yes but
then
there's some things that
me and khalifa could do that i'm
obviously she's talented there's
something that girls can do like right
what makes her talented it's
i mean i don't know that okay some
certain people that are sex workers that
perform
they do things i cannot do
and that's the fact okay because i've
seen it and i'm like how are you how are
you like some of them because we could
do good deep throating huh i can't do
that i just actually
that makes her talented um it's a talent
because i can't do it
and i've tried
and i still couldn't do it so you know
the breathing techniques the
breathing
is the angle it's just the angle that's
it okay so
so in your hat do you feel like only
fans requires a lot of talent
no i'm not saying quite a lot of talent
okay i'm saying that a little bit i'm
saying that they work hard in the sense
that they have to you know even look
good go to the gym
right the hair's going flat what they
invest in themselves is a lot so when
you put all the investment they're
putting for the half of them are born
hot thank you uh
yeah but you could you could literally
say that about a model
if you've got it flaunt it like you're
acting like you need to hide what does
it mean to have a talent like let's
define this word telling cause you could
chuck chucking the one yeah there's a
lot does it mean
i mean
well i mean these days it's not much
because influence is all over the place
and they're saying the talent what i
would say what i'd say is anything that
anybody can do it's not it doesn't
require talent only fans is something
that anybody can do therefore you're not
talented to be an only friend
you could literally say anyone could be
an actor anyone could be a singer but
not anybody
can be a good not anybody can like we
use johnny depp as an example yeah
capacitor khalifa these are two top
ranged people in the industries one is
clearly talented
just get banged on camera there's a
difference yeah i mean they're just
being banned on camera they're making
laughs you're trying to create nuances
to something that doesn't really exist
is it just it no she's getting banged on
okay yes i should get banned on camera
but not every girl can do that someone
says talented every girl can get back no
no no
it's hard work no like no not every girl
chooses to do that
but not every girl is going to stoop low
enough to do that i don't know if it's
back being low because it is low because
that's that's that's that's
some girls only with their boyfriends
and that's it
man and then no but these girls actually
do do that but even if you do it with
your boyfriends you're thinking short
term like because think about it those
girls are gonna get married one day is
it to their boyfriends if it's not to
their boyfriends what's on the internet
forever then one day they're going to
have kids they're not thinking about
their kids yeah it's not a long term
thing but it's literally like at least
in today's society like everyone's very
money hungry and it's such a quick rich
scheme like it really why can't we be
money hungry you go to engineering
because you don't get the same amount as
you would like
but look at the example that we're
talking about we use mia khalifa as an
example we talked about the the
byproduct of participating and stuff
like sex mika leafo wants all the stuff
off the internet she's paid stupid
amounts of money to remove her stuff off
the internet and she still can't do it
and not only that it's harmed her
ability to stay in a long-term
relationship she wants to be she wants
to be in a long-term normal relationship
but other people keep doing they spam
her boyfriend with porn videos that she
used to do so now she's outwardly
speaking on
what she experienced in the porn
industry and she's letting girls know
this is not something that's conducive
to successful life so all this short
term like fast money comes with slow
problems
and that's a fact so a lot of people are
sitting there thinking okay yeah
everyone's money hungry you still have
to do the right things to make that
money right and the wrong way to do
things but everyone's getting banged on
camera some girls literally just they're
by themselves and they're just in
lingerie cooking like not everyone is
going to those aren't the big money
makers but
i mean i don't know this tax of only
found but not everyone has to have sex
on camera to make money from only fans
or whatever they do but let's not talk
about exceptions to the rule yeah let's
let's be specific here most of the
people and only fans do it for sex work
right they're sex workers so most people
that are on only fans do it for sex work
right yeah so let's stick to that
narrative then yeah instead of
just
like
like banging there's so much things to
say yeah sex work i'm talking about sex
work anything to do with sex work i'm
talking about okay fine all of it okay
cool ask a question
so if you were somebody who was very
attractive
not academic at school like struggled
with school
and maybe didn't have very much support
around you whether that's family or
friends and you saw that as a way to
like
alleviate your life into just getting
money quickly why doesn't she marry rich
it's not bad easy not that easy compared
to uploading the video eight nine or ten
girl
yeah
those girls if they go 20 years older
what the hell they have they'll have so
many guys lined up to date even if i can
marry a 50 year old even if they're
having do you want a wrinkly penis do
naked forever
which one if i was that desperate i
would i would pick
but at least you feel like you have a
barrier like keyboard warriors you would
feel
potentially protected by the internet
because you're away from them they don't
have access to you protected at what
cost
yeah because most women who you go
through this like the
the um mental health is through the roof
like most people that do it most people
that are important do not want to be
important i think that the average um
death rate for women in porn is that
quality
is called it's like 36. so they're not
living happy lives like [ __ ] again fast
money slow problems
do you know what i feel like i feel like
in 2022
there's there's women that um yes don't
want to be in the industry of corn and
only fans but it's actually women that
want to be do this is that they actually
enjoy their jobs oh they do they're
addicted to attention and yeah but i'm
saying not everyone's coming from even
fact of like you know has no family or
what have you that these some people
have come from established homes and
there's something they enjoy doing well
yeah because they don't want to work
they'd rather they'd rather take the
easy way out than get a job like men do
or like anyone else's i think as well
though a lot of jobs nowadays they're
seeing the pay comparison to say like an
engineer right the same work in a month
for the only fans and they're saying why
am i studying for a degree where i could
literally just get shirtless in a second
and self like
i guess but then at the point it's
literally like is self-respect more than
six figures at this point it's like what
is self-respect at that point do you
know why it is here because you have to
think like everybody's thinking short
term yeah in a long time
if you look at our athletes for this
example most athletes have to retire
most of them retire around 30. i think
it's 80 percent of them go broke
you're talking about these only fans
people who make a fast amount of money
without building the mentality of how to
manage that money you're going to lose
that money so then you're effectively in
a worse place than you started so then
at least if you have your self-respect
you've got a basis or a foundation to
start from if you go into only fans put
yourself out there lose your social
capital and your respect and then you're
broke as well you're just the biggest
loser in society and and it's legacy one
day you're going to be 70 60. like we're
going to live to be 90 most of us
what
what what's the second half of your life
gonna look like probably alone if you
did only fans 100 oh okay that's them
that's very shocking
okay okay
let me ask the man let me ask the men um
would you wife a girl that does only
fans don't even there's no point even
ask you that question okay okay yes or
no no never like a girl that does only
fans not for me no why a girl that does
only don't wife girls babes
i didn't think it was here
i
just because of my standards though but
i'm trying to play devil's advocate just
to keep but honestly like for me
i want it at least me like very intimate
and i for me it loses its intimacy if
everyone else has seen
everything else that is my prized
possession not my that sounds really
weird like do you know i mean like it's
your human companion so like if i know
my human companions just everything is
everywhere it it loses intimacy because
like you think like i'm not naked in
front of you lot but i'd be naked in
front of my man like do you know what i
mean i think it just loses that for me
yeah just for me personally but
obviously other people have different
stuff like a lot of people in our age
now have open relationships they don't
need that intimacy but for me
i like knowing like the only person
who's seen my man's clothes off is me
and vice versa but other people don't
really care it's literally just people
standing there the lesser there is or
something the more value but valuable it
becomes so if the thing is giving out to
everybody again it holds no value if you
want something yeah it's like most
people buy brand new phones you don't go
to the shop to buy a secondhand phone
you want something brand new do you get
what i'm saying
well i think
i mean i understand where everyone's
coming from but um the the fact of the
matter is the option is there for them
you know we live in this we live in a
den age where
um
there's there's plenty of opportunity to
make money whether or not it's the right
choice or not that comes down to
what you believe in and so on and so
forth but
i don't like to downplay anyone's hustle
because it's been done yeah
yeah so people look at me and think oh
you're a professional footballer okay
but that's easy you just kick a bull
around that's it
when it's not there's actually a lot a
lot that goes into it so whether
whether i'll not agree with
being on only fans and
being a sex worker just on the other but
i still feel like they are working for
it and if there's a market for it
so i have a question how many years did
you train to be a professional
footballer
no it's a great question um
i mean i started
my dad started training me at the age of
six
and then
yeah and then i got scouted at 12 and
then
um
16 until so
most of my life i've been okay yeah how
how many years how many years did bad
bar bam bad what is a bad baby
bad baby train to do only fans and make
a millionaire she's doing only fun yeah
yeah she did on her 18th birthday she
she's made like 32 million yeah she made
a million on the first night yeah
six million
so question how many years did she train
for that
it might have been a hidden skill
i mean her parents would be going to
jail if that was a hidden skill that she
was training for yeah yeah
but um no that that's a fair point she
probably didn't have to train
for it but the fact of the matter is um
she saw the opportunity to make a
million in a day
and she took it now
the repercussions of it like he was
saying
people most people don't think about
that because we're living in a society
where we're so
uh we're so prone to
so drawn to making fast money well they
think the money will keep coming
and that's what and that's what we're
seeing now with this because
um like this is from yahoo finance um
the uk economy shrinks in april as
households struggle against the cost of
like of living
um in the u.s
u.s weekly jobless claims
uh housing hits 13-month low
biden wait another one biden under
pressure as us inflation hits 8.6
percent the highest in 40 years so
there's recession coming yeah
and and that's why everyone i think
wants quick money because it's like
it's it's going up but like the jobs
like an engineer a nurse this and that
aren't going up so people are saying
like why am i studying three years for
something that i can't not really this
girl is making 86 000 a year that's what
is she doing nursing yeah the girl was a
nurse she quit yeah
yeah oh yeah but that's that's still
good money in the u.s eighty-six
thousand i'm nurses don't get that here
that's what i'm saying so you're not
really like it's government
right but what i'm what i'm saying is
it's people with high paying skilled
jobs that are leaving that to do only
fans yeah and the problem is long term
like what does this do to them
well the thing is if the high school if
you would have got a high school already
and you go only friends when their
session comes and going back to my high
school job who's gonna hire you how are
you gonna know why are you gonna do it
yeah but my hand was different to my
real name and why are you almost why
subscribing to my channel
but this no no no but this is what you
don't understand like companies are
gonna find ways to track faces that's
going to be a new industry is finding
people's [ __ ] online because they don't
want to hire people that are a liability
if we hire you and you're like
front-facing towards customers you're
liability yeah my parent like
fair enough i mean what i do doesn't
require me to be searched like that so
i've never thought
yeah i didn't think that was the point
but my handles look my handles are very
different to my name on paper so yeah
you know so yeah are you talking about
do you have an only fans
why you smiling
but if you did like and then you said
you wanted to go into a regular job it
like everyone at your work could not
know but it takes two seconds for a
customer to walk in black i swear i
subscribe to you and then they tell
someone else and it becomes viral
a teacher got found out that was kids in
a primary school fan yeah yeah that's
what i saw but i think one thing that's
important to mention as well is that i'm
not i don't think we're saying here that
only fans is a bad job or this like
what is telling people to understand the
repercussions of your actions because a
lot of people are too fixated on the now
if you don't focus on the future that's
where you fall into silly mistakes what
and i don't think the government should
have to pay for you later if you're
making six figures in a month and now
you're out of money because you made
poor choices like why do i have to pay
for that like why is that my problem now
and that's what's going to happen with a
lot of these girls is they're not going
to get married because who's going to
want to marry you after only fans and
then on top of that
they're going to end up on the streets
because they spent all their money
because most people that get money quick
it goes quick is there a way to do on
your phones without showing your face
yeah of course there's yeah
yeah
so
does that is that the same thing then
like you still have to promote it you
won't make enough money if you're not
showing face trust me
hey
that's a marketing genius
that you need to show your face maybe
you want to draw
i mean there's a thousand people
watching
like i said i have hobbies that i like
to do in my spare time okay
but yeah but no
if you don't show your face you'll make
enough money you need to show your face
to make more money and if you're a
pretty girl you'll want to show your
face
see even that says a lot the fact that
you have to show your face to make the
most money it it
it it just proves the point that they um
i don't know the organ the founders of
only fans or whatever they know
how much is at risk so that's why
they're paying you more so what's your
no no they're not paying your
subscribers this is subs subscribers
subscribe to you only fans was built as
a platform for
artists to actually give behind the
scenes to their fans yeah so
and then what happened was they didn't
put a cap on like adulterated content
and then
yeah people started using well
it could go away tomorrow i mean they
talked about last year they talked about
getting rid of it yeah yeah
and so you don't know how long it'll be
he talked about um
how
i can't remember how we phrased it but
basically it's going to be tough for
them to get investors to take it to the
next level and if they ever want to do
that they might have to get rid of the
x-rated content yeah and so then
overnight all of those girls could be
poof out of the job yeah and then what
it's like there's like influences though
it's like
influencing these kind of people oh it's
like we want to attack we want to attack
like you know
sex workers on only fans because the
only fan is not just sex workers mention
that it's not just that but then if
you're an influencer you're a podcaster
your youtuber like that tomorrow could
go away and then you have no some people
have no skill and they're doing these
they're doing these jobs like all these
passions or whatever and let's say
tomorrow you have less than subscribers
who how are you getting
there's a difference though because
certain so i put it like with with my
podcast right it does i'll always have a
job because i know how to run all the
equipment i know how to run multiple
cameras like there's skills i've had to
take to get here there's some
influencers that come and go just like
that yeah but but it's about building
skills that'll last you a lifetime
but the the issue that a lot of these
girls are gonna have is this as quick as
the money came it's gonna go
it's just the scary part and there's no
skill if they have no skill to go with
it it's a bubble i know i know you
you're arguing no no i i agree with you
yeah definitely a bubble but i'm just
saying that there's a lot of other in
especially now
now a lot of other jobs which require no
skill and get loads of money but it's
just like we always
see it in tech too a lot of tech
companies
attack the only fan skills maybe because
this sex is easier to go for them but i
do feel like there's so much other jobs
as well in this in this right now in
this 2022 where if tomorrow comes a lot
of people are broke and not going to
have you know right well it's especially
women because women own two-thirds of
consumer debt
even though we make 10 000 less than men
i think that's why like well
it's because they're i feel like the
majority of people are used to women
earning less so now they've seen this
platform where like women earn more than
men like
i don't know the statistics but like a
lot of women earn probably a lot more
from only fans than men do and this is
the first platform where men are like
wait because everything else like you've
seen the pay gap everything like that
this is the one thing where they kind of
excel at the pace
do you think
no it's not real is it no no no like
it's true with my industry 100 no
there's i've seen a lot of even
actresses and like actors say like
they've done the same show same modeling
modeling women make more in the modeling
industry if you take into account so the
thing is they're not taking into account
personality traits so 60 of women have
never in their life asked for a raise
and they'll quit their job before they
ask for a raise if we're not choosing to
ask for a raise we can't be mad if we're
paid less yeah and we're picking
industries that we don't get paid as
much what about those sorry what about
those that do ask for a reason that
denied yeah
if they if they ask for a raise and
they're denied they probably don't have
the skills but it's not it's not because
you're a woman you have to remember you
take into account that as a business
owner you're not trying to you want to
grow your business and scale your
business so in a capitalist society you
pick the best to do the best job that
means man or woman so if you have a
woman in a job that asks for more money
she's good at her job the likelihood is
going to give her that job i mean give
it a higher raise
what people what people fail to
understand is that there's
characteristics are involved so women
are actually more agreeable than men are
so men are so even if we're both
women are more agreeable than men so me
me and a woman can be doing the exact
same job i could be doing less of that
job but i demand more wow she's happy to
accept that job of what it is
so i'm going to excel faster financially
than she will then there's other
components that risk may not men men
work in high risk jobs women tend to
stay away from the stem fields so that's
science
men are the majority of workplace deaths
so if you're more if it's a more
dangerous job you're going to get paid
more
even they did a study on uber and uber
drivers make the same money this is how
you work but because men drive faster
they make more money than women would
you say they're more agreeable or do you
think that's just how
a lot of us just see women to be more
because your money i feel like
personally i'm more nervous to ask i
don't have like some manner question
than a woman i feel like it's more easy
i don't know like i i wouldn't more
appreciate yeah i wouldn't yeah like if
you're lost you're not gonna more time
you're not gonna go to a man if you're
lost for directions you'd usually go to
a woman it's it's agreeable yeah trade
agreeableness and it's like i don't
think they're naturally more agreeable i
think we are because historically we had
to raise children like there's
biological reasons the way we feel the
way we feel like when i went around the
room asked them if they'd wife a girl
that did only fans the reason they're
saying no is because historically they
had to ensure paternity and so it goes
back to women like we we pick up on
things that men don't see like every
girl in here knows that when you see a
girl she gives you a dirty look at the
bar
and the men the men are like what what
what are you talking about it goes over
their head they don't pick up on small
social cues but we can and so women we
don't face rejection the way men do in
in society
so i i think we're afraid of rejection
in the workplace that's why we don't ask
for raises
yeah and definitely i mean i've come
across that a lot and i've told my
friends you need to ask for more money
like women
and they're like oh i don't know i've
got enough skill and i've got
same people in the same company
my my man friend is literally he's
demanding a higher higher paid money but
also a higher position he doesn't he's
not warranted to have but because he's
got the balls for it
he gets it and they're doing the same
job but they're very different i do
definitely agree with that but i also
find my industry for example a lot more
women are in production and editorial
which is like the creative side of
things like that if you get someone in
production doing a high level job as a
producer for example as a pm
they don't get the same money well men
work more hours is the other thing and
maybe some do not always statistically
they do men work more hours yeah a lot
of hours so they must work in a lot of
hours yeah well i mean um you're you're
more of the exception you're not the
rule a hundred percent no and i'm sure
and i'm sure you you mentioned i'm not
going to say this on on live but your
income you make more than most men
hmm
yeah so how can we say we're
discriminated against if you make more
than most men um
[Music]
that's a whole nother conversation do
you know what that is that's that's the
victim mentality and there's a quote and
there's quotas specifically for women
they're they're they they seek out in
engineering firms they're begging women
to come back because there is none right
because we don't want to do it we don't
like hard jobs
i don't know would you would you guys
would you guys if you got paid half a
million a year would you go work on an
oil rig
if you're passionate about it why not no
no no i'm saying i'm saying what would
you guys girls no i wouldn't yes yeah
but they might not have that interest i
know halfway i don't want to see oil
yeah i wouldn't do it either what about
you 100 yeah you would do it
uh
not really no it's not it's not
interesting yes
it's a higher percentage of them are
willing to do it it's 50 versus 25. then
basing that off of
your income and how much you're going to
make or whatever like you enjoy no well
no i'm basing it off of the fact that
men statistically pick harder jobs like
electricians plumbers if you look if you
make a list of the countries that are
the most egalitarian to the least
egalitarian
the pay gap increases it doesn't
decrease so the places where women have
more options to choose the pay graph is
increasing rather than do you think it's
because like more time at least in the
past women were even given those
opportunities so now that you've given
them something new it's more like
whoa i never had to like work this hard
working so it's it's unfamiliar whereas
like for a man like maybe their dad or
whatever is instructed into that son or
whatever you're going to be working a
hard working job whereas for the
daughter it's it's not that so there's a
statement but that's why the study done
on egalitarian societies made more sense
because if you look at the west where
women probably are reared to to be more
like women and or stereotypically women
and and men yeah men it wouldn't be a
fair um analysis
so
so they look like scandinavian countries
where they're the most equal so
you're meant to find that the more equal
society the more
alike men and women are supposed to
become but they find that the more equal
to society the more different men and
women become so women tend to choose
jobs that involve people whilst men
choose to do jobs that involve things so
women's going to stuff like hr nursing
teaching whilst men going to the stem
fields and you're going to make a lot of
money a lot more money in the stem
fields
in comparison to
jobs in the public sector i guess yeah
um okay so question um pertaining but a
little bit going back to only fans
um okay so man how many bodies is too
many bodies for you to wife a girl
um how old are you i'm 28.
okay let's do it girl your age 28. 28.
it has to be below 10.
10. 28.
this is like more me as a person
um
at
the way i am and it should know
if she's more than five and it's too
much how old are you yes i'm 25. and if
if it was the same age as you yeah but
then then again like i said it is to do
with my preferences
we'll dive into it anyway no i'm not
insecure like we'll get into it we'll
get into it
okay you guys need context
okay so well we're gonna let's say you
know you went 28 year old girl yeah um
bro say it with chess don't be shy bro
nah i'd say 10 10
okay
okay what about what about girls ladies
ladies
do you guys care about that i don't
really care to be honest yeah you know i
don't really care now
i mean i don't care to an extent if it's
like a guy who's
in more than a hundred oh yeah if it's
crazy
for the sake of sleeping with girls
which there are a lot of guys who do
that loads yeah but like as long as it's
two figures okay
um
um do i what's my number yeah
i don't have a number i don't you don't
care no no i don't care because if i
meet someone and then and we connect and
my personal person i'm not going to
judge you in your past i cannot i can't
be that person in your past because now
we're together and we're moving forward
your past your past but there's certain
names or certain people if you have been
with i might be like oh can't do that
okay what about you do you care uh i'm
19 so like age range dating wise i
usually go like my age to like i guess
22 free so i would usually say
i don't like numbers doesn't really
matter but like if it's getting to the
point where it's like nearly like 20 or
something that's when i'm more like oh
my god you've
been alive for 19 years and you've done
more than me and then i'm like
let me like hold the brain so i have i
have some stats for you guys so if a
girl if a girl is a virgin okay she has
an eighty percent chance of being in a
happy marriage after ten years so weak
for ten years yeah after ten years she's
an eighty percent chance so what between
one and ten she's not happy or whatever
no she is happy i'm saying so
if a girl waits till she's married to
have sex she has an 80 chance of of
being happy in a marriage after 10 years
definitely and if a girl sleeps with
more than five people what do you think
it drops down to 40 okay 20 wait who i
said 40 40 20. not 50.
so 50. so it's 25 percent
if you sleep with more than five people
your chance goes down to 25 chance of
being happy do you know the reasons why
the reason i have a theory
no no so so the reasons why is because
um
basically like a girl wants to marry her
first choice and i think as women we can
all say we can think of a girl
who is dating the new guy but she really
wants the ex
it doesn't matter who she's dan and you
we can all think of somebody right it
doesn't matter who she's dating how nice
he's treating her she wants the ex the
more exes there are the more men the new
guy can't live up to
so basically men are frustrated because
girls get ran through and they're in
their 20s and then in their 30s they're
like oh who's going to put a ring on
this now so you'll say and they're
walking away because half of women over
30 are single and childless but then
yeah i'm definitely one as people but um
are you saying because you're you're
it's to do with sex right and not so if
i'm just dating multiple men
it's no issue but the minute i start
sleeping multiple men it becomes an
issue because my thing is i could date
multiple men some could take me out some
that take me out
and then i can compare my my new
boyfriend to ex look after me in that
way
well the the thing is women bond through
sex so we release a hormone that men
don't through sex so it so it bonds us
to them and men don't release that
hormone they they bond to women through
quality time i want to say and loyalty
that's that's what men bond through
but i think the reason that that
percentage would be so high if it's like
say the first guy that you've met yeah
yeah you've only been exposed to sex
with one guy so but i think that's
actually all like sexes i feel like
everyone like with their first whoever
you've lost your virginity
this is something biological yeah yeah
everything with everything we do no
matter whether it's sex whether it's
buying stuff
the paradox of choice the more the more
choice a human being has the less likely
you are to be able to make a proper
decision so if you have three things and
you pick one you're more happy to be
happy you're more likely to be happy
with that choice if you have 24 things
no matter how good those things are
you're always going to think i could
have gone for that or i could have gone
for that i could go for that and that
goes for everything
and girls are
so a guy will go down and looks for sex
but he's never going to be seen in
public with those girls so a lot of
girls that are five and six fives and
sixes are sleeping with sleeping with a
guy that's an eight nine or ten she
thinks she's on she's on his level
she's not he's just sleeping like he's
not going to be seen in public with you
and so a lot of times a girl can't
replace the guy that she was sleeping
with for a while because she wasn't on
his level
and then she asks the next guy to pay
for her mistakes in the past
and
and she's traumatized from it because
the more people that you know a girl
goes through the more traumatized she is
because the more
social value she loses and it's not even
like social that's true that's true but
what i was talking about is like the
more likely she's gonna have had a bad
breakup or a toxic relationship or get
cheated on and then you have to deal
with it 100
that's why i think they say that men are
judged by the quantity of women they can
get whilst women are judged but the
caliber of man they can keep
yeah so they say
so they say i have a question for you
though so do you think when a man has
sex and when a woman has sex that they
both objectively are the same thing do
you know what i honestly cannot speak on
that because i you guys have said
something that you guys have said
basically that you know women connect
with men they sleep with and i don't
necessarily do that with every man i
sleep oh my god
so i can't necessarily comment on that
because that's not necessarily my norm
my norm is very freeing um
but
i've got my point now but what i want to
say is that
i don't i don't think it's about the sex
but it's a multiple people i feel like
sometimes we really put we really put
emphasis on it being the sex because i i
i've got friends that are virgins and
they're and they're 30 plus and they
still have they still have been through
toxic stuff and other stuff
with men and they are virgins so for my
thing is if we're going
oh yeah i've got a friend i've got
friends
some girls just say that
when you're my friends you haven't got
like trust me i'm the most freeing
person yeah but what i've realized is
for them their trauma is that they're
not giving up so then they're because
they're not having sex with men they're
now going through other issues well okay
there is issues that come with being an
older virgin because like the value of a
virgin
a virgin it goes with youth right like
like so an old virgin isn't as valuable
as a young virgin a lot of virgins price
themselves out of the market because
they think they're worth more than they
are
so you could be a virgin but how do you
look are you an atheist
like no no no no god cares if if you're
a virgin if you don't look good to him
if you're if you're dating a guy out of
your league but i think as girls we
often like lie to each other because we
like gas each other up more than you
know we're not really honest about looks
but i also feel like with the whole
looks thing if you're convinced she
said look good looking person
i do feel like it wipes all your wrongs
like literally if you are you and also
like there's two things you're a pretty
girl you're you're wrong your lungs are
written off whatever you've done anime
except if some man will push all the
cycles you're pretty you're you're
you're correct in some people have
pretty privilege so attractive men get
to be more of an [ __ ] they get away
with it right yeah pretty girls get to
do more hoe [ __ ] and they get away with
it it's just part like lori harvey she
still could have married michael b
jordan was she on her [ __ ] though she
just dated a couple of like a million
rappers million or not she's i mean i
mean i mean but it takes a certain it
takes a certain type of girl to deal
with future why would you why would you
long term do that that's that's the
issue that's the whole community is on
its own still the future being my number
whatever that's all different
conversations right but i'm saying but
it says
it says it says something about her
character
i don't know because if you're dating
these men
thinking like she's actually dating men
like she's she's not like running
through different men or doing whatever
she's actually in it she's actually
going on vacation they're doing things
why can't they keep them
i i don't i think she but she dropped
michael though she didn't want he's
thirty five but she's trying to solve it
and she doesn't want to be married right
now but i'm saying that's that's why men
don't want a wife hoes is because hoes
don't stay they always return back to
the streets because they're addicted to
the attention one man's hoe is another
man's housewife so it really depends on
what forbid that's what we say
i could move country tomorrow you could
forgot my home in london i could move to
newcastle not be at home how are you
going to find out
you're not you're not incorrect some
you're right some girls get away with it
but the problem is it's the damage to
yourself is above all you can you can
you can trick a guy sure okay that's
that's possible but yeah but
the i i've talked to older women and
they all say the hoes get divorced first
because they can't stay they're addicted
to the attention and they're not great
mothers so you build that character and
that character goes with you everywhere
so you can move to a different country
and you're just gonna you can relive
that cycle all over again because that's
your character that's you so what the
wives who were stereos in the past can't
stay but if the husbands were to be a
whole ever
yeah are they the same or are they can
they stay because if they've had all
these other options they're used to the
attention as well now so um
partially you're like i think i do think
guys that sleep around are more like a
lot of men yeah like if i had to guess
but but it's different because men and
women are different and so they say that
a guy
a girl sleeping with one guy is the
equivalent of a guy's 19. like when you
look at his marital happiness the the
ideal is virgin so two virgins is the
ideal that is the highest marriage rates
i i agree i think that's the ideal but
the the thing is with with men when they
get to nine partners versus six their
marital happiness goes up not down
yeah so there's not really as much of a
difference are these are these
who are these stats based on
america
i just need to know basically they've
said americans are the uk are they based
on all colors of one race
if you want rolo tomasi does a really
good episode where you get his name's
rolo tomasi he does a really great
episode where he links all of the
studies but it's based on multiple
studies in in dif with different sample
sizes in different places and they're
surveying people
yeah i feel like i like to know okay
because i think stats and stuff and
surveys are amazing and i love them but
also about it asks about the environment
or what they're in and if you're doing a
multi if it's a multiple range of people
and cultures and
groups that's great because then i get
to a holistic point of view but you're
talking about like a like a straight man
and a gay man i'm pretty sure they have
not got the same necessarily the same
kind of views or values or even
experiences that make them different
than different but this is kind of one
of those things that i didn't even
really need to see a study to me it's
like common sense
like
women since the beginning of time men
have had multiple wives and women have
had one strong man it's i want to say
the stat is ayton
oh my gosh what is it it's
40 of women reproduced historically were
80 amended so it's like two men to every
one woman
but do you think it's possible for us to
evolve from that because i think we have
yeah it's about it's written up into our
dna this is like a biological component
who we are like you have to think the
whole of human civilization in 2022 now
things are different no no we're we're
sleeping with the same guys still if you
look at the dating app data 100 of women
want 20 of men and sometimes it's even
smaller than that if you want a guy
that's over six foot that's 15 of men if
you want them to make a certain amount
of money that's that's a smaller
percentage of men if you want a certain
ethnicity that's a smaller percentage of
men if you want like women are sleeping
with the same men today
one out of one out of three men under 30
are virgins or haven't had sex in a year
said again one out of three men under 30
are either virgins or haven't had sex in
a year wow that's hard to believe
no but there's once you once you see it
you can't unsee it and so as a girl
there's a whole group of men we just
don't see think about when you were in
school i mean there was a small select
group of guys that everybody knew about
the rest of them just were invisible
think about it
or even when you walk into a room
like
you'll you'll find that like you'll be
able to remember people and you maybe
there might be a guy who'll go oh i
remember you from this event
[Music]
i know one woman yeah
used to go to a gym that um that went to
yeah and she
she was sexually free and she
she made it known everyone knew about it
actually sexually free
and um
i can't tell you
how many guys from the gym she she slept
with
and then um
the thing is about
men we talk as much as some women think
we don't but we talk and then we say oh
yeah yeah so
i came to a point where she was she was
dating not sleeping but actually dating
someone from the same gym and
uh the other the other men that had
already slept with her started talking
about her and we just we just thought oh
we looked at him and thought well what
are you doing with yourself we looked at
him as the loser it came to the point
where she was now requesting marriage
and then because what does already come
around
he already knew um that she had slept
with all these other all these other men
prior he did not want to marry her and
what happened was
um even when it came down to her
children because she had i think uh
three or four children she would look
for a babysitter for her children to go
and sleep not with her boyfriend
but other men so the the the sexual
addiction addiction was already there so
i say that to say this like when
when you are sexually free as a lot of
these well we're calling them actors
[Music]
calling them actors when you are
sexually free you have to know that it
will come a point in time where you may
not want to do that anymore and as men
i don't want to know that you slept with
my bedroom you know i don't i don't i
don't need to know that you know i don't
it did for me it's not a fact it's not a
thing where um i would want i would
accept it in my household so
i don't feel like a lot of these actors
on only fans or whatnot they think about
that
one thing that annoys me
and again i'll say that
doing only fans being an actor as you
want to call it you're free to do as you
please do what you want the one thing
that annoys me is when those same women
then ask for high value men because to
me that makes zero sense are you are you
a high-value man to be so annoyed
what's your definition
asking the question like no i'm not even
trying to get here
first of all i'm making the point so
after the points made then we can go on
to the other question what's your
definition of a high-value male though
like i don't know what that means a
high-value man if someone that's has is
strongly as masculinity
financially um um that's the word
financially endowed if i'm actually
endowed and just he controls the show
like he knows what he's doing with
himself what's stable in the masculinity
it's it's quite a bit of shame
what does what do you mean by state why
so a man amanda's in his true masculine
so he's confident he's strong um he's
dependable um he's reliable these things
once a man takes those boxes he sits in
his in his as a high value mail
he becomes high value it feels like a
bit of a caveman mentality that's what i
was yeah i was getting that and i was
like
it feels like why does it feel like okay
classify that as a high value man like
why do you need to be overly masculine
the thing is yeah we can say that um
it's kv mentality but are these are the
ideals that free hypergamy women also
create so you perpetuate these standards
because the men that you go for are
meant that tick these boxes so your
biological impulses lead towards these
men so you can't then call it a
caveman's cayman ideology when the man
you're going to sleep with tomorrow is
that man that's probably taking longer
do you think it's because a lot of women
are exposed so that they'll like they'll
turn on the tv and all the men they're
giving like he's now giving it
to white women
i'm saying that by the way
women pick so you can't then say this
that now this is what you go for and
that's what you've been going for
a lot of people go for what they've seen
like if you were just brought up seeing
very hyper masculine men and as growing
up you've seen that as what meant women
are that's hyper matter
you do though a lot you seem like styles
that's recently though that's very
recent it's not growing up one direction
harry styles is very different to him
now do you know what i mean it's very
different like
now you'll see women who prefer men who
are more feminine or in touch with their
feminine side i'm not saying you where a
lot of women
you'll see a lot of women settling for
men that are more of them no a lot of
women who want that who can maybe look
after themselves a bit more or just
stuff like that they want that they
don't want more of the care man they
want someone who's gonna relate
like relates them on an emotional level
because a lot of times masculinity isn't
coordinated with being emotionally
available i mean a lot of women now
especially women want an emotional
connection with a man they don't want
more a lot of women i know is not this
isn't this isn't a fun study and this
actually makes women look really bad
okay but if a woman sees a man cry even
once she doesn't respect him the same
and she loses attraction to her when was
this made though this study because
documentary you can watch on it that's
very recent like that depicts this yeah
and this is this isn't fun but women are
telling men to be emotionally available
but that's not what we want to sleep
with
i don't know but i do think things are
changing a lot so potentially for like
the younger generation as they come up
they might be very different to maybe
how we are now then we can wait to see
what happens with those resources right
now in the world we live in right now
these are the facts of the reality
because the things we've been exposed to
is very different to what they are now
like we're saying harry styles this and
that that may be their first man that
may be like a girl's first man they've
seen on stage and like oh my god that's
what i like like
whereas like we
a lot of women and a lot of gay men
they've seen like the hyper masculine
men who looks after everyone does a b
and c we don't really see that as much
now we'll see shows where maybe the
woman goes to work and the woman well
they force it on us they force it on us
you kind of have to in a society you say
that but
sitcoms have been like
perpetuating the idea that the woman is
the stronghold of the household right in
a sitcom because it's a comedy that's
what they're making
the simpsons look at marge she's the
strength of the household look at homer
he's a useless man
yeah look at bob
he's a joker he doesn't take serious
anything serious look at lisa lisa is
the smartest girl you'll ever meet like
they
i don't you can't get more but who
brings the money in homer yeah that's
what i was just gonna that is that's
fair but yeah marge runs the house the
other thing is that the house not the
money so
the other thing about masculinity is
about leadership
yum so he's not a masculine man he's not
a depicted masculine man and that's why
i think society finds it it's funny as
well because it's like oh look at this
man who doesn't look like you're making
excuses for the facts that we're
portraying so we're telling you facts i
know you're saying well if you add this
in then no these are the facts and
you're not you're trying to mix it into
it's avar you accept reality for what it
is
or you you look at the differences
that's happening so you're arguing that
things are changing until we see those
changes right now we live in this
reality right this is what women are
attracted to i do think things are
changing i think men are becoming more
feminine but do you know what that's led
to women sleeping with a smaller and
smaller and smaller percentage of men
so some dating app statistics say it's
five percent of men that are sleeping
with everybody 100
yeah 5 10 15 20 are sleeping with 80 to
100 of women if we're talking about
leadership then
i mean if we're saying that masculinity
is based on leadership and that high
volume based leadership then my god
there's not many men doing that anyway
and that's one of your friends because
we've got society
that's one of the reasons
it's not even about yes we've got the
fact that um societies letting women
lead more what have you but some women
have no choice that's in the matter
so and i feel like
because we have a lot of i can't speak
for all men we have some men that want
to go and be wild have fun and not have
responsibilities women have stepped up
it rather could be because men made
children and they wasn't around and the
rest of it so i thought because because
you're 19 right yeah and i'm 3 i'm 35 so
i'll dif what how have you seen men is
quite different and how we portray men
is very different i we wanted leaders we
wanted men to run we wanted mented
leaders and they couldn't but
wait but women leave more so when it
comes to marriages you're talking about
kids and fathers not being there yeah
one we all say that women mature faster
than men anyway so that's one fact the
second is that women um divorce men 70
at the time 70 some stats say 80 and if
if you're college educated we leave 90
percent of the time isn't that what i
have it's mostly to do adultery and
stuff like that right
it's fine that's an adultery two things
that i have there there are two but
remember men and women cheat at the same
rates it's very close it's 23 and 28
so
they get caught more than we do
they right right so so arguably women
cheat more so that's why you can't put
adultery on the men if we're doing it at
the same time i'm just saying that for
me growing up in
asia i am being millennial the way that
men were portrayed to be they never and
a lot of them did not actually reach
reach
didn't make the cut so we've had to
become more right but did did you make
the cut
in what sense well i'm saying like you
don't have a ring did you make the cut
but don't want to get married that's
another question well that's that's fine
if you don't you know what i'm saying
but your women still do and that's and
that's i think you know what if you want
to be that kind of woman that was
getting married and be a certain way
then i agree with you wholeheartedly you
have to be a certain way to get what you
want you can't be out here thinking
you're going to live a certain way do a
certain thing and then get the man you
want it has to be bargaining you have to
compromise right that's my issue my i
always say to my friend if you're if you
can be single and you can ride that bird
ride that bird do you sis and write it
and be that person if you can't
humble yourself because the men out here
want a certain thing right and let's
face it if you're not saying you're not
you're not going to get when you want
and you and you make enough income to be
okay right
you'll be okay but here's here's the
problem women
over the age of 45 that are single and
childless have the lowest rates of
happiness oh my god successful career
women yeah successful and they make that
makeover it's like 50k a year but
there's other women that on the other
flip side that are okay so i think it
depends no no you're you're
we're talking so you're bringing up the
exception i'm talking about the rules
yeah and so the rule is that if you make
it to a certain age and you you're gonna
you're gonna get out of the dating
market men prefer younger women
yeah
so and so you get to a certain age life
starts to take away options for you we
don't know the reasons why these 45 plus
year old women are in the situation that
that they're in maybe due to their poor
lifestyle choices before that's led them
to this so
some of us may not may not feel a sense
of sympathy towards them
if the oh for being i'm not saying to be
sympathetic but i'm saying we should at
least give younger women the information
so you can prioritize what's important
i i think i agree i feel like
we've we've now lots of do's and don'ts
we don't give we don't give
young people whatever people the
information they need to make a sound
decision so you even get the only fans
people that are saying make only fans
it's loads of money you can make six
figures in you know in two days but
don't tolerate repercussions of maine
six figures in two days the same way
women say get married young you know you
get my job have a husband for life
repercussions come with that as well
i've got friends that love to be single
like me and they got married they got
married young because i guess you always
look for something you don't you don't
have so when i'm like up and going no
kids i'm going holiday i'm going
whatever they can't do that because
they've got some other things to think
about so i think you we always have a
bit of envy to another group of people
that you're not but i do agree with you
have to give people all information like
a sound decision well because life's
about trade-offs so yeah some people
that get married young feel like they're
missing out but long term they're
happier typically
their their marriages tend to last
longer if they didn't live with the guy
before
of it said that again yeah if a girl
doesn't live with a guy before she's
married the marriage lasts longer really
imagine that is um i don't i think
partially it's probably the values of
people that don't live together before
true yeah
yeah you've got a point yeah okay i'm
going to read i'm going to take a second
to read super chats we've had a decent
amount
um okay
okay um info vader respect to the white
t-shirt guy in the corner when he talks
about these topics you know he
understands a lot of the deeper issues
bring him back the savvy ninja a
feminine man and his wife are sleeping
there is a strange knock and noise at
the door at 2 am who should investigate
and why
the assumption is that the man is tied
to the fact that he is supposed to be
masculine
bernd schmidt the crap that women want
emotional emotionally available men i
heard this in the 70s and the 80s most
didn't want them smack tagging and um
black calm no
gal
don't want a feminine man wendell coven
um example of women wanting feminine men
where calm gold is rare when it when
which in turn in turn makes it valuable
if everyone could access gold easily it
is now not rare anymore anymore thus the
value goes down if a woman has been
passed around and many have had her her
value goes down wendell coven i'm sure
or i'm curious what do the ladies rate
themselves courtney jones not only that
but it
promotes the sex industry that is
heavily patriarchal focusing
furthering the mindset that women are
just sex objects for men's entertainment
this is backwards um s-t-f-u-f-f-s
exactly the sin damages the sinner the
most corty jones it is absolutely bad
for society only fans should be banned
it is online prostitution predatory as
it preys on the young lonely men
sexually sick very commonplace smack
taken on top of the comparisons to exes
women's also lose the ability to pair
bond with the more people that they
sleep with cam tech the closer you are
to a virgin the more likely you are to
be able to be marriage material to me
every time i have a shoot i clicked a
link um okay every time i have another
partner um
i have to compare to x did this better
than y i hate that i have the data to
make that comparison i wish i didn't
sarah martinez i'm a 10 year female
combat veteran and worked my butt off in
every aspect and i still would rather
have an easier desk job for less pay pay
choice december 0.81 in 20 years men
will be dating robot women and
won't need to spend money on them so
women will get what they want work live
and be alone stf uffs girls do hard jobs
but they are people oriented men are
object-oriented and
object-oriented work pays more than
people-oriented work northwest pearl in
the u.s a woman who was given the choice
to quit or resign from the local
sheriff's office is department because
her work college colleagues found out
that she had only fans read devil's
studio 30 percent of all only fan model
incomes go to a predominantly male board
are the women on the panel content on
making men which and therefore maintain
and enrich the patriarchy they want to
remove
uh gus women support sex work because
they're afraid to be judged if they end
up having a 304 phase why empower sex
work if you wouldn't do it to yourself
bernard schmidt i would argue a
prostitute
um on
the way i would argue a prostitute on
the has
has to oh i would argue a prostitute has
to work harder um let me refresh and
just make sure there was no other ones
uh yeah there was a female yeah okay i
thought i saw some come in um i think
about robots as well it's already
happening in japan hold up okay hold on
one second hold on so one antonio 35
tinfoil hat could it be la could it be
that cultivating less masculine men is
better for the government a less
masculine man is less likely to resist
the state and defer male
responsibilities back to the state and
clay bring back sarah um
he's coming back tuesday guys um info
vader oh wait no we did that one already
okay
um thank you for the super chats guys
they're going towards we just got a
third camera today which is very
exciting yay
um and we want to get a camera for ish
so
send money
yeah if you don't know what ish looks
like send money
hello
okay um
so tell me do you feel like
women
um typically understand the consequences
for their choices or do you feel like
it's a surprise later it's a surprise
100 percent surprise later 100 is a
surprise what do you guys think yes a
surprise yeah i think we um
choose choose more on just our initial
emotions
oh yeah yeah
yeah
yeah i think some don't care as well
do you think i
agree with that
that's crazy though like you all
understand
that it's a surprise later you all still
make choices that that doesn't consider
yeah because sometimes you don't think
things through yeah
women i don't know some women don't
think things through this impulse and
they go for it sometimes you could be a
bag of emotions like our hormones go up
and down all the time so sometimes i
could be great because i can't be great
and i can't necessarily always balance
that but then this is why you
self-reflect and you learn you're then
cognizant of those emotions and then you
understand that when you feel that way
you stop and think
instead of acting no but men you don't
don't do that's why
that's what you said earlier
men do tend to be more logical whilst
women tend to be more it's easier for us
to say that when we don't go through
something every once a month like it's
easier for us to say it when we've never
had to do it
and i'm not trying to say yeah it is
easy or harder i'm just saying that for
me personally yeah when i self-reflect
when i try to teach myself growth to
understand myself better yeah when i
feel a certain way i stop so when i was
younger i used to get into a lot of
facts i was a very angry person i would
smack people up but then when i started
when i started to understand the
repercussions of my actions the way it
could land me
when i get angry how young was this but
you taught you how to do that my parents
and how you know
and then i then then i i carry on
um
well we're chemically we are chemically
different every single day but i don't
but i don't think that's an excuse for
poor behavior no just because we didn't
think something through like why why
should the men have to deal with that
but then that's like saying how um
sorry like men
are prone to be more like
aggressive and stuff like that people
say that but then is that an excuse for
them to no they ever feel it's not is it
you know what i mean like it goes both
ways yeah but i think the difference is
when when women have a standard we're
praised for it and when men have a
standard they're shamed
for for example um fat fat phobic
okay um [ __ ] shaming those are those are
all to take away the consequence for
women's bad decisions
um
okay so where whereas a woman if a woman
says oh i want to keep my standards high
i should never settle
the girls gas her up everyone gasses her
up wait i even asked the girls a
question like
so if if is it okay to ask your guys
he's tired
no i feel silly what do you girls think
let's be honest is it okay to go after
guys yeah definitely yeah so do you
would would you sorry ask them hi yeah
you think it's silly to us no martial do
you think he's okay no i don't think
it's silly to ask but i don't think it's
needed
like are you talking about a dating app
so like a guy you've never seen before
you find him attractive is it okay to
ask him his height absolutely yeah if
you're like a more taller girl you need
to know if okay the man is tall because
some people don't so in reverse um is it
okay for a man to ask a girl about her
weight on a day or not
if you want i mean if if you want if
that's you know you can i don't believe
in the hype thing because like i've got
friends that like four feet so the
question first of all is it okay
yeah i might have asked me a hint before
how fat how how big are you okay what
about girls what do you think if you
asked me and i sent you a text saying
okay yeah i'm eight stone you're going
to think oh i know exactly what that
looks like
i could be eight stone and five foot
left i'll be asking you whether it's
whoever you think it's okay because
weight no height yeah which is and
that's and that's yeah yeah and that's
to the point to be fair your weight is
within your control whilst your height
is something you can't control so
wouldn't it make more sense to be okay
to ask about something like weight
in in
compared to height i hear what you're
saying but that's why hinge is great
because a guy has to put his height on
there anyway so you don't need to ask if
he hasn't got it on there then there's
for a reason these are some of the
double standards that where women are
praised for certain things that men have
to they have to face the reality
straight on yeah and it's the same thing
with only fans like if a man has no
skills and no job he's homeless
a girl can make six figures in a month
just starting and only fans if she was
born attractive
but i say if she's born attractive if
you're not born attractive then you're
going to be homeless like everyone else
absolutely now you can pay to be
attractive so
trisha paytas makes a lot of money on
only fans i do not think she's trying i
don't think you need to be attractive if
you go big back and big boobs
funny enough the highest paid like
people in sex work are people that look
young like that that look like kids yes
because men want that a lot of men want
that though
they're attracted to fertility
the younger the mulch if you survey men
between the ages most women peak at like
22
at 21 some some even earlier because if
you survey men from 20 to 80 and you ask
them what age do you find women the most
attractive they'll say 22 23.
i think even on netflix they did a blind
smell test both for women and men women
who tend to be more attracted to men
with high levels of testosterone whilst
men were attracted to younger women and
that's based on smell that was hot was
she had high um
so women so so they got men to sweat
they've got meant to sweat and then you
based on smell who would they most
attractive to without being able to see
the guys and they was attracted to guys
with higher testosterone when they did
the same for men to women um when were
attracted to women who were younger but
what was because they were young what
what was it that made them
attractive
as well it's fertility so men are
biologically predispositioned to want to
spread their seed
like what do you know what the gangas
khan stat is where like it's like 1 out
of every 100 or 1 out of every 50 people
in china related to kangaskhan because
he was just slaying so many hoes
like i had so many concubines yeah but
we have different reproductive
strategies like a man's reproductive
strategy scattergun spread your seat to
as many people as you want whilst a
woman whilst woman's is to to bag the
best they can get and hold on to it
because that's what that's what ensures
safety
to make more people
you're spreading those teeth to make
more spread to spread your genes
so to make more people so to make more
humans look more human your genes your
your specific genes i know so
that means you're gonna make a baby
right okay but you're just spreading it
you're just
out here no condom just scattering
around we are biologically predisposed
to do that that's what we're born to do
can i just scroll back to summit real
quick sorry um just where you guys were
talking about your number with a girl
would be 10
would is that like lower than what you
would go to just where we were talking
about double standards i just want to
check that
real quick yeah so you would you like
you wouldn't sleep with more than 10
girls that's your cap yeah i would have
sleep more than 10 goals yeah i'm asking
you both at 28.
because you
with more than ten guys just you know
where you were talking about double
standards before yeah yeah so i just i
was just checking like i was just
kidding i think she wasn't your number
bro
what's your cat when do you say no i've
had i've had way too much sex i want to
stop now and settle down listen yeah we
play by different rules did it
wait
i'll i'll land on that so we obviously
as many women we play by different
standards yeah so when i say men or men
women are born of valley whilst men
enough to create their value here so for
a woman acquiring sex is
as simple as walking out in that street
you're going to get sex right now yeah
so you can have zero value like um
tangible value and just being born a
woman means you're guaranteed a seat at
the table when it comes to the sexual
marketplace as a man before you're
granted the opportunity to have sex you
have to become something you have to be
worth something so how can you then
place the same value on sex for men
as women and that's that's and that's
the only double standard that doesn't
benefit women
and it's really not that crazy
with the provider role
so we're okay with that double standard
because honestly if you're okay with
that double standard why isn't it not
okay for a woman to want someone a bit
bigger and want that provider then
because maybe she doesn't find a
provider in someone that is she is okay
yeah because you were saying
it's not but then it doesn't mean she's
any less lovable if she's a certain
weight does it not whereas like if it's
a high school at least for like a lot of
girls like taller girls they just like
the taller men because it gives them a
sense of comfort
a girl is that making you all women want
tall men that's not true no because
because like i'm five two i don't need
so like
okay what does a woman of a certain
weight give you whereas like a man of a
certain height maybe they're attracted
to to
think physical yeah hips naturally isn't
it genetic like the wider the hips it's
more yes so that's why women but that's
why women are sorry not women that's why
men are attracted to the hourglass
figure right the wide hips but yeah
that's not that doesn't mean rolls
that just means wide hips yeah and and
men can't help that they're not
attracted to bigger women in general
that's why you see the most attractive
or the most powerful
men
end up with models yeah that has money
not because everybody else no i'm saying
we're taking the people the two people
with the most options
they typically are thinner women and
rich men yeah a lot of models are just
slim and slender they don't really have
the hips to
have what you
yeah do you know what i mean whereas
like you can get not always but a lot of
curvy girls secrets
they look good i don't know they do but
they're very slim and slender like
i don't think men are looking at least i
don't think you guys are looking at
victoria commanders being like oh yeah
that's going to be perfect for my choice
you don't know what girl i'm praying
i mean guys have different types that's
true some guys prefer you know more of
the instagram body where it's the
hourglass and some guys prefer more of
just the skinny slime yeah that's true
but
at the end of the day
it's still we're talking about in
general men prefer thinner women yeah
yeah
but remember that not everyone has the
same
um
basically everyone has different options
and what the what they prefer and so
when we're
shouting out these stats or whatever
let's let's be
um
rather
objective about it and say that it's
some not all because i know i know men
personally that
that prefer
um
a woman who's bigger than them yeah and
i know
um
i know men who are short are
but they want a really tall woman yeah
yeah
i think that's what oh no the short guys
they love the top they do yeah
we don't we don't love them like it's
not
but but but the thing is we're talking
about in general like if we talk if we
talk if we spent this podcast talking
about the exceptions we'd be here all
day we'd even get moving yeah there
would be no point in having a
conversation we still need to mention
them why
no you're right
exceptions don't make no sense to the
bigger society but i'm i'm always not
always but i'm mostly reception to the
rules when i say things i'm thinking
about speaking to them so when i say
things i'm thinking things how how i
think and how i react but i also
understand that society doesn't think
like me most girls will quote exceptions
not not not the rule and it's just to
alleviate themselves of the
responsibility of having to be factual
in the moment do you think so hundred
percent happen
accountability is the one key word when
you throw that word around like how many
women really claim that and i can say
i'm truly accountable for my actions we
all here just said once you ask the
question about um
um being of understanding the the
byproducts of certain decisions we make
and we all know that yeah we make
impulsive decisions yet you still make
the wrong decision so accountability
will tell you that okay to better myself
and make better decisions i'm going to
take kind of really for my bad decisions
and then better myself but you all
willingly said like oh no while i still
make impulses now but that doesn't mean
that we don't learn from previous things
that we've done
in the same way that you um learnt from
like your aggressive behavior when you
were younger that doesn't mean that we
don't learn from that and are conscious
of our behavior
if that happens again from from what
i've seen i don't think most girls do i
think they go to toxic relationship
after toxic relationship after toxic
relationship then at 28 29 when they're
running out of time their biological
clock is ticking they run to the nice
guy but in terms of relationships that's
because they haven't learned they
haven't understood what was wrong with
the relationship before
their own behavior right how many times
do you have to learn no but they haven't
learned they don't know what what 20
times they don't know what's wrong with
40 times i don't know
i don't know if you could put a cap on
how many times because people learn
people no no only because for me
i've been in certain situations would
never go back to so i learned very quick
very young
probably why i'm single now because if i
was going if i was going with the judges
and going with the flow i would probably
be of a man now but i learned very young
very quickly
that i have
that it's a lot of
it wasn't right for me i was i wasn't
ready for relationship when i was young
because therefore i took myself out of
that stuff and worked on myself if i was
just to go free and then i probably
would be with someone else i think
there's a lot let's take a strong person
right well stick that back well i mean
don't get me wrong some girls do learn
and make better decisions but the
problem is we're just thinking about us
because why does a man have to deal with
that but in a sense why does he have to
deal with a girl that can't learn young
like why why wouldn't he just marry a 22
year old because she's yeah unless
that's what also what's crazy about that
though you're saying that but then men
also prefer
young women that haven't learned that um
how what so exactly so why young women
that that create more problems for me in
the future so whether or not you've
learned okay i can i can help to teach
you the right way to do things i don't
want to have to teach you the right way
after bear men have run through you and
then it becomes a more of a hassle for
me
to try and develop this relationship
because you have bear problems do you
know
okay i hear that to be fair i understand
you do
okay because there's two there's two
different kind of females there's
females that had a lot of sex a lot of
men and they've had their body count is
very high
there's females that have not has a lot
of men and their body count is low i
have friends in both sections i know
people in both sections
and in my experience
even though you're saying i don't know
if a woman has been run through whatever
and all those kind of things i have met
women that have had they've done the
right thing they've got less partners
they're being submissive they've been
all these things
but their man is still going and having
to go through things that he would have
gone through the girl who's been run
through it because it's how i think it's
hard i've been treated by
by people which reflects on how you have
to come and deal with that mess so do
you are you're you're basically saying
that the girl with less bodies still has
trauma is that your problem yes yeah
yeah but we're talking about like a
balance of probabilities so if a girl's
been with 50 dudes versus five dudes
who's who's more likely going to have
more trauma yeah just the balance of
probabilities
oh do you know what and you know i mean
i've always said i
like
rolo tomasi has a quote where it's like
it's not the number it's the number of
like guys that she saw alpha as alpha so
it's like the number of
men that she's comparing you to but the
bigger the number is the more it's just
a balance of probabilities but when like
when you were talking earlier about
dating and sex like
if sex is just a physical act you can
sleep with a guy that you're not dating
and
that whether that be a one-night stand
or just a fling
like why does that necessarily need to
affect you in that way that it puts you
through trauma it doesn't you can do
that yeah like that's totally fine but
men don't want to deal with that
that's like they're in dylan anyway i
mean they don't deal with it for some
people
special accounts plus you have to
remember that again the characteristics
of a woman that
frees you up to that capacity it's going
to have other implications in that
relationship
and again why would you as a man want to
take that risk
what kind of implications are we talking
about here so if we're talking about
like promiscuity and the effect it can
have on a relationship
if that man isn't ticking all the
biological works boxes whereas he
probably would be would have been before
if the woman was less promiscuous the
likelihood is that she's more likely to
stay we caught the statistic before that
70 to 80 of women leave their men it's
not men leaving it's women leaving so if
men are out here having more sex and
women are having more sex but as a
consequence of us both having more sex
you're less likely to stay with me then
what you're doing is causing a problem
to successful relationships so you're
actively breaking up nuclear homes
because you can't maintain your
discipline then women are not leaving
because of sex even because of financial
reasons that we said so it's not about i
don't i think it's sexually significant
did you know one of the number one
indicators of divorce is the woman out
earning the man
i can see that yeah
but it goes back to because the woman
one of the reasons is because the woman
is around all these men that she wants
but i know but then if if we're talking
about is it is it sex or is it money
because if it's if she's if she's
leaving because he's not owned enough
that's different than this no that's
selfish but that's it's about being a
selfish woman that is selfish if you're
leaving and breaking up a home because
he's not earning enough money that's
selfish
so it's okay to want that but if you if
you sign the papers if you got married
to him and now you think you're above
him because you make more i remember
remember we're talking about
characteristics here so yeah with the
characteristics of a woman that wants to
free up for everybody when she is around
men that she wants she's going to act in
those
those feelings whereas a woman who's
more disciplined is able to say no to
things
because she's had less
is more likely to be sexual
and they say that 20 of men are raising
a kid that's not theirs that's why they
don't want a promiscuous woman they're
afraid they're going to pass their
resources on to the wrong
um
on to a kid that's not theirs well
unknowing or knowing nothing i'm not
knowing so how did they get the
statistic don't know it's dna tests so
when they come together when they find
out i just want to know how that was how
that was possible we literally spoke to
a lady yesterday that said that the guy
was the kid was 11 years old before he
found out the woman just came clean
because our conscience couldn't take it
no more mad
this is what might have to go through do
you think they st do you think the women
stay or do you think they settle because
it's like
if they've been exposed to airbnc men
one toxic one really nice they know how
then to spot a really nice guy and a
toxic one whereas like if they've had
maybe one boyfriend and that's the only
toxic one they've had that's the only
familiarity they've had with a partner
do you know what i mean so sometimes
having say a promiscuous girl they have
that knowledge now you see where you go
ahead like men do because you're saying
men can spread their seeds so they know
what they want logically logically that
makes sense yeah then we have the data
to prove that that doesn't work so what
you're saying would make sense in an
ideal world but ideally that doesn't
actually happen why do you think why do
you think fathers were so involved in
the vetting process for women we don't
make good decisions in men on our own
like that's why half of women over 30
are single and childless because the
average age of first marriage is 27 to
28 in the u.s and in the uk it's 31. so
clearly how involved is your dad going
to be in the vetting process for a
husband if you're 31. saying that as
well look at the
the idea when people say oh she has
daddy issues
because without without a masculine
presence to guide you you're bound to
make babies father presence
not all fathers are masculine yeah
father a masculine father a masculine
presence that is able to tell
right from wrong when it comes to men
what about beethoven
i'm just saying because not all men are
like not all men alpha so
i think having
alpha back then i think having a father
figure for example my
my godfather that brought me up
he wasn't what what macho man he
provided he doesn't mean much or man i
know but but we said earlier that's what
kind of what people go to dependable
what do you say macho okay masculine
masking for me is a macho i don't see it
because
oh my god that might be a problem
let me let me tell you what i think of
when i think of masculine just from like
a woman's point of view it's a guy that
doesn't put up with women's [ __ ] so when
i think of a beta guy i think of a guy
that just bends over and does whatever
the girl wants and she's he's just will
do anything to make her happy but not in
a good way like he's a kiss ass and when
i think of a masculine man i think of a
guy that is not afraid to say no and put
his foot down and he enjoys being the
leader in a relationship
because we don't we don't like men that
we can walk all over
correct yeah yeah like like the the nice
guys they're not actually nice they're
just trying to buy your attention
with with things instead of just being a
masculine man
yeah i don't know because like my
godfather for example
he like he would lead but
my grandmother would choose what he's
going to wear when they go out
some men that's like no what are you
doing but he's like whatever different
dining doesn't take anything for me to
put on the clothes she chose out for me
in the wardrobe but i realized that now
that maxine is not always a beater man
or he's not a masculine man but he
definitely run he ran the household but
so does she so maybe i've seen different
dynamics happening men and women have
different roles in households i mean 100
i mean some masculine men
they're not afraid to dish out
responsibilities to women that they're
good at
like my my parents ran a business
together and my mom is very organized my
dad isn't she did a lot of the
organization type stuff right and like
the finances but at the end of the day
he's dishing out the responsibilities
she's not
he's the one he's the one saying what's
happening if there's a big move he's the
one making the decision she's not and
that's part of we talk about submission
at times for her opinion
in making those decisions before making
oh yeah i mean of course he's gonna but
but she had to earn that he didn't he
didn't just off the bat give her the
ask for her opinion all the time
how did she earn it loyalty and showing
that she's competent and giving him
peace i imagine as well yeah i mean
because my mom um
my mom and dad went to different
colleges and basically my mom told or my
dad told my mom you can either move to
me or find a different boyfriend and she
moved to him quit and then she ended up
getting a teaching degree she quit her
teaching job to work for my dad and
helped him build a multi-million dollar
business they had 10 kids
but you know in modern day they would
say you know don't take that risk for a
man it's only going to end up don't quit
your job for a man it's only going to
end poorly my dad would say a similar
thing my dad would say to my mom or he
said until us is that i would see the
bigger picture while she sees all the
finer details so everybody has their
role to play within the system
behind it like there's a lot of i am
was with like a lot of um filipino
people from like the older generation
and in their
like culture at least back in their day
was
get for the women as well get an
education first if you used to get
married before an education the family
would disown you because it's like
one snap of a divorce and you've got
nothing and you've left us in the
filipino culture
really that's interesting it wasn't so
much about it i i don't know about like
all around that continent of asia but at
least there they said to me
education always comes first and then
when you have that education backed up
then you would go pursue maybe a
relationship or whatever because if you
left especially of a woman changing your
last name there's nothing there holding
you as much towards them so it really
does depend on the culture without
interest the presence with people i
don't know if you want to get a
statistic but yeah no the reason what i
was looking up is um i when i want to
see how westernized the country is i
look at the average age of first
marriage in a country so one country i
didn't realize was so westernized is
ireland um the average age of first
marriage there was like 34 and 35.
because the more traditional it is they
get married younger typically is what i
what i've seen this is just anecdotal
but the in the philippines is 27 and 29.
so i guess they're westernized too are
they now yeah well at least the people i
speak were much older so i don't know if
it was just because older times like you
said your parents would have said
something different because maybe in
their times it was different but i know
now
it's probably more
westernized a lot of culture is now
though isn't it like even like the
eastern south and yes messing [ __ ] up
i think with with the point that you
were making with the example you gave
about your mum and dad and their working
relationship i think that worked well
because your dad did not
um that's what ox did he ask for her
opinion before making i think a lot of
men take this um
this title of leadership and run with it
to the point where you almost forget
that you have a woman there who's almost
meant to to help you essentially what
are the examples of that
where do you see that a lot of time the
men that that take the title of
leadership and
uh use it to the point where in any in
everything in everything they they think
okay i'm the leader i'm going to make
all the decisions without asking for
your opinion without but essentially
that's your part that's a dictatorship
yeah yeah yeah yeah essentially but
that's that's what i'm trying to say so
it's a thing where if you are going to
to demand that to ask for
um oh the title of being of being the
leader you have to know what it actually
entails and i feel like a lot of a lot
of people don't know how to do that so
with a lot of these things a lot of a
lot of what we are discussing is all
well and good but with if it's not
taught to the younger generation they're
growing up they're going to grow up with
with misconceptions about the realities
of life well i think most masculine men
that i talk to are okay with asking for
a woman's opinion like because on on
youtube i meet a lot of guys that make
it like stupid amounts of money like
more money than i'll ever make but i
know more about youtube than them and
i've had a lot of them ask me for advice
on youtube i think they just know like
they understand that men and women have
different roles i think it's a real and
i just want to say also you have to
remember as well that just being born a
man doesn't give you the entitlement of
leadership yeah
as she said yeah you have to earn this
you have to show the qualities of of
what a leader has before you can have
the title leadership so like
you and a lot of men watch kevin samuels
and think oh yeah whatever he says is
right and i'm you need to submit to me
no these things have to be earned unless
you prove yourself as worthy of these
things you're not entitled to them so
let's make that clear you know what's
funny so i i said i i like to run a lot
of my decisions through men so my like i
talk to my dad i get a lot of advice for
for things on my channel and just like
business decisions i also have a manager
that's a guy and i run a lot of my
decisions through him and so um i always
say that i like to run decisions through
men because they are they're better at
making decisions than they think more
long term and i just think that's an
um an advantage that men have right not
all men but there is one guy who sent me
an email that just was like the subject
was a man to make your decisions and he
was basically propositioning like making
my decisions for me because he was a guy
do you think
do you think they're like a man just as
seen more as a leader role whereas like
if a woman wanted to be like head of
anything it seemed more as a challenge
because i feel like it is in a certain
way like a man could go for a spot and
it's
more respected upon where it's like say
like a woman is a head of anything
it's very like foreign still to us which
is kind of sad no i mean i think it's an
advantage oh my gosh everyone
yeah every time i've worked in corporate
america they're trying to move me up
because they they have quotas they have
specific quotas where they need a
certain amount of women working i've
always worked in like male dominated
industries i think that's one of the
reasons my channel took off yeah is
because i'm one of the few women that
talks about this stuff like i think
being a woman is an advantage in
business i've never felt disadvantaged
in any way in the world a few years ago
i can't remember what year it was but
then i think they changed the tax system
and then a bunch of companies made women
ceos
literally just obviously when positions
became open you just see it out but this
these when i was still working in
finance i was on linkedin every day this
new ceos won that new ceos and that new
ceo's woman so that she said
it's actually very advantageous
in this day and age it's an advantage to
be a woman seeking out leadership roles
or seeking those niche especially highly
specialized skilled roles because they
did they want you in tech they want you
in engineering they want to make the
company look good it's branding is a lot
of different things but they want you
there so now is the best opportunity for
women to get into these high paid
roles i'll be honest i used to get in a
lot of trouble with my mom because i
used to say that
i think men
again
not an exception but just a rule
naturally are more born leaders than
women are and my mum would be like so
you don't think you could be a leader no
that's not what i'm saying i think i'd
make a great leader but
just as a generic rule i do think men
by nature are better born leaders
which goes back to like you were asking
us earlier would we
um like make impulse decisions based on
our emotions etc like i do think men
tend to be calmer and
probably a lit a little bit okay calm
i'll take that one back a little bit
more more thought through sometimes with
their decision-making like they don't
have the emotion attached to it so they
can step away from a decision
and not think about how it's going to
affect people necessarily
whereas women
again as we talked about um go more to
people roles in terms of their jobs so
when we make decisions we think more
about how it's going to affect the
people men
are
less emotional with those things well
you can see it with debt
i mean we we make less money than men
but we spend more money yeah i mean the
world plays in our insecurities so yeah
it's a great whale that's that's amazing
that's like a back to a victim mentality
no no but i mean yeah in the sense that
you know we you know if you want to get
down to if i just want to be a natural
woman no we've got no makeup no wigs
like no not shaving not doing anything i
want to do
it comes tied into what's attractive
what men like so we've been told a story
of to be to be a wife to be a woman to
be attractive with these things and i
feel like a lot of the things that women
buy into whether it be the bbl the
makeup the wigs the hair the tan the the
toenails the everything but to the
clothes we wear it constantly feeds into
debt but it's so freeing when you're
like f all that i was gonna be me so how
are we sold a story when there's
movements like body positivity what do
you mean so if we're sold a story of
what men like and it's for men and the
media is for men and we're sold a story
about what men like why is their body
positivity because there's a set of
women i feel like that are going against
that so i think i feel like body
positivity isn't for the women that
are conventionally pretty or beautiful
it's for women that are saying you know
i'm not
the kim k's or the whoever out there the
bad bees on instagram i'm a woman and
i'm gonna be put and i'm gonna celebrate
my my body and who i am right now
that's the story we're seeing in the
media
so
but only now not when i'm not when i was
70 to 80 of consumer buying decisions
are made by women everything we see in
the media is marketed towards women yeah
but who's making a decision it's not
women
who makes the decision women do at the
end of the day because women they spend
their money
the decisions come with where the money
is we spoke about the majority of women
want to get married want to be wise want
to be a certain way want to be a certain
thing therefore if they're going to
you're going to create a story about you
just cream and you'll be a better wife
you stick by these shoes you'll be a
better girlfriend you're going to buy
into it you have to take responsibility
for your own actions like again you're
pushing the blame onto something i'm not
pushing the blame i'm not
cause maybe because i
work in the industry where
we sometimes you want me to think a
certain way even with podcasts or
whatever people say certain things get
people to think a certain way i'm not
talking about the exception i'm not
talking about exceptions to the rules
about the masses the master told be a
woman be a wife be a mum in order to be
these things buy this stuff but that's
not what we're told with feminism we're
told chase the back i've been told from
a young age chase the bag you can do
whatever you want there's women
empowerment there's not men empowerment
i'm bad but don't do it i mean there's
there's i don't know
is there not men i don't know there is
you got that one there
i'm not gonna say anything i'm not gonna
believe it and it's not
and and honestly in society that's not
true if you see anyone shame sex work on
social media what happens the comments
is filled with people saying you're what
slut-shaming
i don't see that on my mouth i've heard
there's a ton of social conventions that
protect women from a lot of these
a lot of these things and again like you
said body positivity positivity is one
of many but we're saying basically
because for so long as a woman i mean as
i can say i always speak as a black
woman growing up i didn't see no black
women on tv let alone if it was a black
woman tv it was tyrant banks it was
diamond campbell that's all i saw for a
very very long time if i'm not seeing
you you didn't watch oprah
no i'm i'm i'm i'm
okay
okay so and it says like secret even and
in the uk it was worse so the uk there
was like i grew up in the 90s
and early 2000s
my mom when i was very young
where are black people on tv where where
am i so i was very conscious of that
from very young
so it's not seeing not seeing myself my
skin tone my my shape on tv was a lot
for me so now that i'm saying women that
celebrate the way i look because i don't
look i'm not i'm not a 10 out of 10 and
i can tell it on the chin i'm good with
that so where i look the size like the
size i am i'm a plumper woman i'm a
bigger woman
i'm a darker woman seeing that now on tv
and being positive has done
me the world of good not because i want
to get a man but i said okay i i i um
and there's more people like me out
there because
coming from a white neighborhood i
didn't think people would like me out
there but now with social media i do see
that and it's better for me so just a
question why does it matter because i'm
i've red hair and i don't really see
tall pale gingers on tv and i just don't
care like what does it matter if i see
someone on tv that looks like me i feel
like it's gonna be quite damaging as
well like if you've been especially for
like a lot of people of color like the
shows you've watched like it's not
you're not seeing yourself and it's
something it is sometimes like maybe
younger you would have been nice just to
see like a redhead actually but oh my
god like
it's just it's just a bit more it's not
a big thing
but even like just little things like
you'll see now with the movies they make
and the people they cast you'll see
little children growing up to be just
uplifted by that film and that could
become their comfort film and that
motivation like i'm not does i'm not
ugly because how can i be ugly when a b
and c are on the tv screen right but the
reason we brought this up is we're
talking about women spending too much
money yeah and so what's
the positivity to yeah well no because i
i said that because you were you were
sort of saying we spend more money
because of society and so then it kind
of led into body positivity but i'm
saying what does that have to do with
spending like uh spending too much money
i just feel like that's our own decision
and we spend too much money because
we're bad with money not not because of
society oh i don't have bad with money i
don't know yeah because i i think
there's a part of our brain that like
lights up with impulse decisions that
doesn't for men
but did you mean in the sense of we
spend more money because of society
because we're trying to
reach the standard that we think society
expects yeah that's why we spend more
money
no i think we spend more money because
we're bad with money one of the number
one ways that women are in debt is
college debt in the u.s anyway that's
nothing to do and when i'm having these
shoot when i'm having these
conversations i'm talking about the west
so uk and and the us because i'm from
the us yeah but i just think women
like every girl i know is bad with money
oh my god
oh my god oh my god yeah i give my money
to
a girl i'm i'm bad at money yeah i am
bad i am
i'm the kind of person why is that sorry
why um because i grew up poor so now i
have money i want to spend it and i
think i could get when i was when i was
poor simple as that there was time i
couldn't eat so now i can eat i'm going
to buy every eat everything i want
because i can that's my thing i couldn't
buy certain clothes now i can i'm going
to buy it that's why i'm that's why i'm
bad when does that stop for you it's
stopping now because i'm 35 and i've got
to retire soon so for me
and that conversation i can't but also
i'm making more money never mind before
so for me
i can't make it by decisions or my
spending because i want to get old one
day i will not have to work hard anymore
that's what i've changed so that's why
i've added money but now i've got i've
got friends that are women
more than men are good man i give them
much hold this for me and save it for me
until i learn to save without touching
money i don't think women are bad
women not about money i mean i know are
better money than men are in my opinion
how can you argue that when the fact is
that most of consumer debt is held by
women
i i'm saying that i'm i'm not arguing
that i'm saying i don't think i don't
think many men don't spend but maybe i
don't remember spending saying that my
plane that i people that women that i
know people that i know women are better
than men my mom my aunts they can save
money they can the men will go and try
and flip their money try and so they
might try and become an entrepreneur the
woman's at home counting the pennies
make sure all the bills are paid that's
how i thought i've seen right yeah i
think sometimes in the older generation
that's the thing but with women women my
age are terrible with money they're
always on what's it called sheen oh [ __ ]
and like the girls i know they spend
money like it's water but is that not
because of society as well that they're
like so women feel like they can't wear
an outfit more than once yes because
they'll post a picture on instagram
whatever and so that's all society-led
and therefore they're constantly buying
new things it's other women it's not for
the men it's other women that shame
do you guys care if your girl wears the
same outfit every day
like it's women and women i think it's
because they make poor choices and they
don't have any self-control
like i'm like i don't know
accountability yeah so it's definitely
some women um the women that i i am
around um they they they're not like
that they're very much um good with
money it's more
it's more for me it's the men that i am
around because we make a certain amount
of money
and some men not i was
crazy crazy stupid with the money um
i'll give you an example
um i remember
uh the first
uh when i moved away is where i was
playing i was painting i was playing in
jupiter premier league and then
the first um the first month we got paid
because they would get paid monthly
whereas in the uk you get paid weekly
the first month we got paid a few a few
days after one of um one of my teammates
came up to me and says um i need more
money and i'm just like what do you mean
you need more money what did you do with
your money he said i just blew i just
blew 6k i'm like
like how what did you do he said women
he went out he so
anyways that's that's his poor decisions
um mostly the way the way i grew up is
is is the women that
that
that are more financially literate yeah
they they the one that that handled the
money they're the one that that that
distribute the money and especially
coming
from um i'm originally congolese so
um
the way in our cultural well it's
changing now
but the way the way it used to be the
man will go to work the woman will go to
the market the man will come back home
um he'll put the money on the table
um okay this is the money that i've made
and then the woman would then distribute
like this money is for the rent this
money is for food this money is that in
the oven right well i'm happy that
you're around exceptions but it's not
the rule
women still own the majority of consumer
debt
you've also got to take into account
that you're you're around footballers
yeah who
have a tendency and a reputation not to
spend money well
in terms of how they end up after their
career yeah yeah so so like i can
understand you your point of view where
you find that the men around you are
spending money money frivolously while
women are saving it as well that men are
more likely to pursue high risk high
reward as well so if my household my dad
was the entrepreneur whilst my mom
worked so naturally he's going to spend
a lot more money than my mom would but
at the same time when it's successful
we're good to go and the other thing is
with with the man when he spent that
money society doesn't say it's society
making you spend that money
well i mean they just say it's your poor
decisions like this this no no guy is
gonna talk to his guy friend and say oh
it's society making you spend the money
okay no you just made the poor choice
yeah you're right it's point it's poor
poor choices i hunted agree with you but
when you're gonna say no though but when
you guys said about you let me to the
club when guys are popping balls it's
not girls and balls
it's really not it's like i've been out
in front of 10k in one night i'm looking
around like
what's your point though so you're
saying that you're saying um you're
saying that men don't make messages they
don't impulse violence
when you go to the club they do
right
i'm saying by and large men make better
financial decisions than women and we
can see this because men make more money
and they and they spend less women make
less money and they spend more so by and
large women make
worse financial decisions i think it's
because women generally are trying to
compensate for something i don't know
what
but i think that's what it comes from i
think it's because women lack
self-control do you think
yeah i think i think we're trying to
satisfy something
we're we're trying to buy the latest
outfit buy the latest botox you know how
many girls i know that give botox at
like 24 25 26.
and they can't afford it it's not like
they're making enough money it's all for
attention i feel like about about every
like just younger people in general how
do you afford all this stuff
they can't i could not and i cannot i
don't understand how do they do it all
they can they don't that's the point
they can't
the people that have that fast lifestyle
like i grew up in a one percent family i
know i know what money looks like and
i'm telling you the richest people i
know don't spend money like that i know
someone that's worth probably 50 to 75
million roughly and they've driven the
same car for 20 years
like it's just a mentality it's
definitely if you haven't had it you're
always going to want if you haven't had
it you're going to want to try and get
it and then and somehow unfortunately if
you haven't come if you've come a place
where you don't have it those stuff
those things make you feel good
unfortunately and it's very sad that we
live in the western society where having
things having stuff makes you feel good
about yourself rather than having
character and being a person not
necessarily that just comes with
self-reflection and and again
understanding yourself so a lot of
people in the west arguably aren't
self-aware we just do things you don't
think about why we do them hence why
we're having this conversation a lot of
girls will just go out and then just do
things and not think about the
consequences so you spend without
thinking about the consequences you do
only things that figure out consequences
all these things are
a lack of cognitive cognition and making
good decisions for yourself yeah it's
just women are always bailed out for bad
decision we always have an excuse for
women and we never do for men
and we can even in this conversation
nobody when he was talking about his
friend that spent the money nobody in
the room said oh well it's society
making him spend it but everyone we
talked about it the other way around oh
it's society making her spend it i think
men like his friend that that spent a
lot of money has definitely got complex
like say the guys that pop bottles in
the club they have a complex that
they're trying to fulfill by popping the
bottles and getting the baddest beers on
their table it's a complex we've been i
think where women have been
i've been coming to a corner to admit it
men have to haven't got to admit yet but
most men believe if i'm people of you i
wanted that bad as it be so i bought a
bottle of champagne i wanted the thing
to do i'm the guy in the club but we're
not ready to manifest conversations yet
i think we've already said the man
popping bottles don't even get the girl
anyway so
what are you saying what yeah it's for
sure it's just yeah but then they'll
come to your table if you don't actually
have snatch your business but you'll get
the girl to your table at least
whether if yours would open
so you've seen the tic tacs where the
girl grabs her drink and leaves yeah
like you've seen this
well known so like the popping bottle
things okay like certain men to display
ego and display power and presence
though these things
but again like if they can afford to do
it it is what it is but then if you
can't afford to do that's another
question but based on the information
provided most men are more likely to be
able to afford to be that frivolous
if they're doing it if they're doing it
um okay i'm gonna read some super chats
real quick okay
thp network one of the biggest problems
today is ladies want future to behave
like russell wilson and this does not
exist exist thp network rocks with pearl
and the crew thank you i think i've seen
one or two of your videos 90 free topay
look at the pot calling the kettle black
is the phrase would you females say well
not all pots are black no so why do you
all do that when it relates to women i'm
clay ish you deserve this camera bro
i appreciate you it's coming soon
honestly
send money so you can see what ish looks
like makes sense let's go
humble beginnings um 4 20. they didn't
learn lady the vast majority of girls
today learn a lot of toxic things from
social media and their single toxic
friends it's still up to them to choose
where to go from there uh chris hundred
dollar super chat
okay women in their 20s partying and
hoeing 30s baby mamas 40s bitter 50s
angry feminists this is the circle of
life i support the viewpoint of
feminists on your panel um of the
feminists on your panel as they help
keep girls to be side chicks for guys
like me i appreciate that
you're welcome
[ __ ] 100 bucks
yeah keep it coming keep it coming um
emma um
not even a message just a super chat
thank you um
derek curry
men most men prefer thinner women
because being slimmer is associated
associated with being healthier which in
turn will produce a healthier child
passionate rebellion this is unbearable
women refuse to take accountability for
anything the uk economist it's very
simple high quality men prefer healthy
women to breed healthy kids an obese
person tells a man that she lacks
discipline to eat eat healthy pgop i
wouldn't say
fatality is a major factor anymore as
more and more people our generation in
our generation are deciding not to have
kids passionate rebellion the women are
fighting every point they can't for one
second just listen to what the men want
um marcus moore the lady on the left
needs to stop picking on these guys you
can obviously tell she's lonely and
doesn't know how to talk to men stop
shaming
brit cormier um wanna update your studio
faster have the feminine feminine guests
pay money on the jar and the table every
time they start a sentence with i think
upgrades will be funded in no time
passionate rebellion learning to women
listening to women dodge accountability
is exhausting to the moon is it a bad
thing
isn't it a bad thing i can see high
value women on only fans for the same
price as a happy meal
tinfoil hat could it be
that cultivating less masculine oh i
think i did this one okay let me i think
there's one or two let me just refresh
it yeah
um
uh
oh oh [ __ ] michael wooden i'm gonna
simple little for the camera he wants to
see what you look like ash
500 super chat
[Music]
also i wanna i wanna point out guys like
the video because this is the most
people we've ever had watching live i
think we broke two thousand seven
hundred at one point
yeah
yeah yeah um
oh god i can't say this hot hocks yes um
you pick the partner based on what you
want your future to like if you don't
know what that looks like or what you
want generally we will continue to miss
the mark it starts with us first wes
sandals natural hair nice body in a
sundress will be anything that you can
find on fashion nova says 95 percent of
men in the world only spend 50 bucks um
marcus infinity when you lie women buy
90 for toby i'm a mexican male kid i
say myself as he-man i did not he-man to
look like me men rise women move in and
bring other women to their down to their
level emma another five dollar super
chat thank you um the
joe thyming men don't usually don't
usually don't focus on makeup and
clothing most of that is intrasexual
signaling the savvy ninja did i do this
or no um i can't i can't remember it's
okay i'll just do one more um there is a
ton of responsibility being the leader
of a home and a business if that is
pre-shaped it's on you as leader that is
a heavyweight
uh last super chat i have is bring
sorrow back so oh no i started with thp
network that's where i start okay okay i
have two more um lay haiva the issue is
that people see a gap in an area of
human activity and immediately presume
it's due to discrimination that's where
we get quotas from jason asano i have
straight friends from the philippines
they do not work um they do not work
that way marriage is so important to
them above all else
um okay i think that might have been
everyone
michael wooden we gonna get that camera
soon asap
thank you jay ben um came here from
anton daniels channel and the
millionaire morning show keep up the
good work love seeing these convos on a
global scale did anton did he react to
one of my videos let me know in the
comments
um joe rogan saw one of our clips guys
fun fact
like like the video um and you know
bother him in the comment section trying
to get us on
him
yeah
yeah tag him okay so
do you think
that
do you think that
only fans models will be on the streets
in 40 years
or do you think they'll find a simp to
marry them
nor on the streets but knowing something
that they'd they'd want now so like they
could be in the flashy apartments now
okay but in 40 years could be something
like down and out
that they didn't want but they can't
afford anything else
yeah i think i think with the way
with the way men are they'll probably
find us him they'll find
um i don't think there will be would you
say on the streets okay
um
they
they will help they'll have a fine
they'll
they'll have a hard time finding um a
man
who would um
take them in essentially you you don't
think they'll find anyone
um they'll find someone
but probably not the high quality man
not the one they want they'll find
someone okay what do you think
i i think they'll still find someone
because
it will become more normal now for a man
to meet somebody and for them to have
said
previously i had an account on only fans
obviously that didn't exist before and
it's not the same as saying i work on
pornhub mm-hmm cornhub cornham
okay go ahead
i honestly like the amount of money most
of them make i wouldn't see them being
on the streets in 40 years okay i just
can't envision
all that going stupidly i mean i can
because it came quick so it's going to
go quick it's definitely green
but i feel like it won't be on the
streets because if no it's going gonna
sound quite wrong but if they're smart
they'll just have a baby by a rich man
that would then keep giving them money
to give on their lifestyle which a lot
of females do do so i feel like these
pretty girls that everyone says are
pretty and they're only fans whatever
because look at the looks or whatever
you want to say they might then find a
guy
because they're pretty to just fold into
their bs and live happily ever after
it's the women have to grasp they're the
ones that might end up have nothing
because they've had to graph like drake
baby mama yeah but she got lucky that's
what's up in hot sauce and stuff so you
know yeah i mean i think i think he
learned and that's and that's the thing
that's not saying about men saying let's
scat your seat and throw a seat that's
great protect yourselves because women
out here some women out here are on crud
and if you look a certain way and you've
got certain money
you are going to be the one paying child
support for kids you didn't want
unless you're going to blow out so you
know it's very very cool that's the
other thing the laws are against men
it's not even illegal for a girl to
steal a condom
it's a no disseminate herself it's not
illegal that's crazy no
that's so bad and the other thing is um
we're incentivized to do bad behavior
because as you just you just said it
right so we're rewarded for bad behavior
we get pregnant by the wrong guy do you
think that men should be able to have
financial abortions since we have the
right since we have the right not to be
a mother should they have the right not
to be a father oh
that's a really rough one i cannot sell
right yeah go ahead yes i think i think
i think it's very upsetting
when
you've done the act which was great you
loved it lasted three minutes whatever
had to put it in there no we've done
that
and then you've now got the consequence
of the act yeah and it's very
and it's it's very upsetting when a guy
doesn't want the child and the girl said
i'm going to have it anyway because i
feel like the man has any every right to
walk away yes she's made a human and
it's very unfortunate
but he didn't he doesn't want it he
doesn't want any to do with it you can't
then force a guy to have the child keep
the child or pay for the child it's on
you narcissus as i would say to girls if
you're going to have a child make sure
you can financially support that child
before you say i'm going to keep it
because if you can't don't go and blame
no man for not being there it's
different the man said have my child i
love you we're going to go together you
believe him you go in together and he
leaves but if you're there saying i want
a baby i want a baby then whatever
happens during your baby is between you
and your baby as well as where i see it
right and it's rewarding bad behavior
yeah definitely consent it's
incentivizing girls to
catch a kid off of a rich guy
that's something to some girl that's
their dream their dream is to find a
rich man have his baby and be cool
that's why some guys take their kid from
the from the woman they can because
there's a certain story he's a
basketball player he's quite young he
had a baby by a woman who just wanted
the baby to get child support so he was
actually going through battles to try
and get the child to live with him says
i've got a pain in my child support
because it's crazy what she did a lot of
women do do that i'm really really
against single parenthood and women
trying to have babies just for money i'm
really really against that right it puts
the kid at every statistical advantage
that you could possibly put a kid in a
match yeah disadvantage yeah yeah i hunt
and agree i disagree why would you want
to why would you literally bring a child
into this world no not got a father that
makes no sense especially a father that
doesn't want them it's selfish it's
absolutely selfish hundred percent
because you're you're putting your your
want for a check above a child
instead of finding the million guys that
would probably date her if she's
attractive enough to get a guy from a
like a baby from a rich guy i think it's
very situational because there's like we
can't speak for all women but there are
a lot of women who could get pregnant by
mistake and they physically cannot oh no
a child no not from a rich man no not
from a rich one just genuinely like okay
got pregnant they physically i have
friends who are like maybe i'm not ready
but i can't physically bring myself to
anybody right so there's very there's
six there's six layers though of
protection one you can get you can get
an iud if you don't get an iud you can
do you can get the pill if you don't do
the pill you can take a morning after
pill if you don't do a morning after
pill you can do an abortion if you don't
want to do an abortion you can give the
kid up for adoption and i think i missed
one because i'm pretty sure oh and and
you can require and you can require the
men that you sleep with to wear a condom
so there's six layers of protection for
a woman all the man has is a condom and
so if you pull out what it can pull out
but that's not good it does work
it lowers the charge it's not that it
works don't guys wear condoms
right so so at some point it's a choice
she made a choice hundred percent i
think also the ella one for example it's
120 hours it works up to 100 it's just
five days yeah
women need to know know your body clock
because you can take no no pills no no
and know when you're fair time we're not
fair tell that's the first thing you
need to do as a woman know your body and
seven track your yeah check yes
you track your cycle okay cool didn't
check the cycle didn't wear condom
there's a one after the one after which
is which is 27 two hours afterwards but
worst case now you've got five days cyst
to sort your stuff out and you don't at
this point you can't bring a number
yourself well it's a choice at that
point i mean you had seven seven layers
it's literally a choice
yeah my mom got pregnant when she was 17
with my dad but they gave her the kid up
for adoption
wow yeah and then we we meet him later
later his name his name is greg he's
pretty cool
but i think it's about being about bff
yeah making sure about decision at the
time because she wasn't going to be
selfish
she was selfless she thought about the
kid before her
a lot a lot of a lot of other young
adults are not young people but
a lot of people don't necessarily think
about that concept i think of everything
not being married being single whatever
you're going to start bringing kids into
this world even men want to scatter
their scene and have loads of kids
everywhere or be a woman that has loads
of multiple kids it's becomes a human
being that you're talking about a human
being is gonna have to be put in a place
where you're going to put trauma on him
for no reason because i'm not asked to
be born and i think that's a serious
question to have with people that you
can't be out here having kids anywhere
everywhere because you because you can
because you earn 10k a month so what
that kidney on there every single day in
their life to be their dad to be their
mum and i people talk about enough so
what about you guys uh financial
abortion yes or no
yes
yeah
yeah
now i think ultimately i would say i
just i do feel very sorry for
men when it comes to women getting
pregnant because ultimately they don't
have a decision regardless of whether
they're in a relationship or it's a
accident whatever it is it is the
woman's choice at the end of the day so
yeah i just think it's a techie one okay
so but you you at the end of the day you
would say
yes okay yeah yeah yeah what about you
yeah so we all agree yes
[Laughter]
the audience is going to switch on you
they're going to be like you know what
she's based
what does that mean what's basically oh
based is like it's good it's like she's
cool yeah
i'm learning the lingo yeah yeah okay uh
well i think i'm gonna
wrap up the show on that why don't we go
around um first off thank you guys all
for coming this was a really good show
you guys are all really great guests um
go around say your name or not your name
oh my gosh any final thoughts you have
and where the people can find you you
can start
final fours final fours i say
as a society we need to be more
cognizant of our decisions and we we
need to get out of this idea of this
victim intelli that it's always someone
else's fault because once you make a
decision you have the responsibility of
the choice that you make so we need to
have more self-reflection we need to be
more worth the decisions that we make we
need to stop pointing the finger this
victim mentality is too prevalent for
our western society and it's not
it's not conducive for building up a
better society for all
um that's where you can find me as you
know um one of the hosts of the domino
effect podcast
we're gonna have uh we're gonna have
pearl on as well we've got an
interesting one for you coming um my
personal um oba underscore vbe
um on instagram and tick tock
all right guys listen um great show
today make sure you follow um uh pearl's
channel as well um thank you for
everyone that's that's done that already
final thoughts on this look we live in a
world where you have options right
and it's up to you you're in control of
your life but just know that with every
um
every choice has a has a has a
consequence so before getting involved
in anything just know what it is that
you're getting involved in what you're
potentially putting up for risk and just
know that you have to be accountable i
think that's a word that everyone tries
to run away from but you have to be
accountable for your decisions so yeah
good luck to all the only fan users as
of where you can find me um i come on
all socials it's king bears so
k-i-n-g-b-a-v-s love
yeah like previously stated everything
just comes down to you and your
decisions like you just got to think
about what you do
um because it all just comes down to
yourself but yeah um follow pill's
channel and you can find me on instagram
and it's teigsford
um again just want to say thanks to
pearl for having me on
my final thoughts definitely like
completely agree with everyone about
accountability
but
whatever job you choose to do be that
only fans
a toilet cleaner anything engineering
that is entirely up to you and and no
one should judge you for that
um so yeah that's kind of my closing
thoughts i'm also a host on a podcast
called gossip station
um so go and check us out and also my
personal instagram at el gray
um just literally with everyone else i
think as well
think of the short term how it's going
to benefit you in the long term as well
always with everyone
um
new money is always good money we have
to remember with everything like that
because money can be quite poisonous to
everyone and
yeah i think everyone's stated already
and thank you so much for having me
again you can find me on instagram it's
just
tr3v.g
drive.g on instagram
yeah thanks for having me loved it today
loves it um my final thoughts is when
you when you're alone
at night and look in the mirror do you
love the person you see in the mirror
and if you don't change it if you do
carry on because that's ultimately
ultimately
what matters that you love yourself more
than anything else and i think also we
need to stop putting emphasis on
material things and money because the
whole thing is the whole only fan thing
is it's quick money it looks it looks
attractive but
let's say equipment is not long money
and i think young people especially
young people think about the choices
you're making before you make them
because people would sell you something
as gold and it's not gold you can find
me on teletalks on instagram twitter and
the rest of it and i'm just yeah that's
it
okay so i'm going to read the final
wait
i'm going to read the final super chat
so
um
courtney harris the camera is a myth i'm
on to you pearly it's not a myth we're
going to get issue camera
if you don't want to see what if you all
want to see what he looks like
some money
um okay chad question for the panel list
if the majority of women claim that they
are the prize then why do they hate it
when they are being objectified uh
that's a really good question but we're
going to save that for next show i'm
going to refresh it and just make sure
there's no more
um
that's a bad boy question what that's a
good question yeah that is a good
question
okay guys um do not forget to subscribe
to the channel also sign up for our
memberships for our exclusive behind the
scenes content thank you so much for the
super chats today um we are definitely
closer to getting a camera
like the video on the way out don't
forget to subscribe and we will talk to
you next time